thank you for the introduction and thank
you to the organizers of this event and
welcome to our distinguished visitors
from Todai we're very thrilled to have
you here and look forward to setting up
new collaborations a major challenge in
Environmental Management for our
generation is that air pollutants have
large impacts on regional and global
climate change but in complex ways
involving both warming and cooling
mechanisms as we've been hearing a lot
about today and this creates complex
trade-offs and synergies in policy
development and may have even led to the
false dichotomy that we can have clean
air or a cool planet but not both so the
most important air pollutants that
influence climate are Travis Varrick
ozone and fine mode aerosol particulate
matter we call them the short-lived
climate forces they typically have much
shorter atmospheric lifetimes than
carbon dioxide but higher radiative
efficiencies our ability to evaluate the
climate and equality benefits of
mitigation strategies involving the
short-lived climate forces is currently
seriously limited by a lack of
understanding of their coupled
interactions with land ecosystems that
have up until now being rather poorly
represented in models so I'm going to
tell you about some very new work today
that my groom have been doing to try and
improve the representation of this
interaction and the impacts that it has
on climate that the short-lived climate
forces play a major role
an anthropogenic climate change is not
controversial and it's depicted
hopefully we can keep on seeing it in um
it's happened before it so it's clearly
depicted in the iconic infamous IPCC bar
chart which we've seen a few times today
and so from a global warming perspective
our best estimate of the net effect of
cooling short-lived climate forces is
that they are masking the committed
greenhouse gas warming through the
Industrial Revolution by fifty percent
that's huge from a regional temperature
change perspective in the current
climatic state at Northern Hemisphere
mid-latitudes the anthropogenic aerosols
are having the same strength impact on
surface climate as the long-lived
greenhouse gases so they're not small
players and moving beyond temperature to
impacts on hydrologic cycle the aerosol
a pollution has larger impacts on
regional precipitation patterns than
greenhouse gases so in this sense we can
actually consider that it is the
greenhouse gases are masking the the
aerosol effects on hydrologic cycle have
the hydrological cycle
so ultimately it will be policymakers
who are charged with making some of
these complex decisions on trade-offs
and synergies between air pollution
abatement and greenhouse gas mitigation
it's up to us the scientific community
to provide them with the information in
the best possible most useful format
than that we can and up until now we
have been quantifying climate impact in
terms of changes of concentrations of
atmospheric species single individual
species in the atmosphere but changes in
atmospheric concentration are a symptom
not a cause of the primary drivers of
anthropogenic climate change those are
the emission sectors themselves so this
single species approach is useful if we
want to try and understand global
climate sensitivity or attribution of
historical forcing to human vs natural
impacts but if we want to develop
climate policy it's not particularly
useful there's no information here about
the actions that are driving the forcing
actions affect multiple species
oftentimes with opposing climate effects
so coal burning is the clear example of
this that emits both carbon dioxide and
sulfate at the same time it's also
backward-looking this is our inheritance
there's nothing we can do about this now
we have to learn to live with it so
myself and several other groups around
the
all to have worked on developing an
alternative approach that is
reorganizing this chart in terms of the
real drivers of climate change the
economic sectors and we also
purposefully choose to adopt a
forward-looking perspective because it's
more relevant for policy and we argue
that this approach allows identification
of emissions reduction scenarios that
are win-win-win and by that I mean
they're good for climate in the near
term they're good for climate in the
long term and they're also good for
human and ecosystem health so here is
the result from our first global
sectoral analysis the sectors are
ordered here in terms of increasing net
warming and the contribution of each
chemical species is shown for each
sector these aren't the results on
fairly short timescale so for the thirty
year time horizon now the first thing to
notice about this chart is that the
sector profiles differ greatly so it's
very important to do this analysis
secondly what we can quite clearly see
is that just how important the
short-lived climate foster effects are
relative to carbon dioxide at least on
these timescales for all sectors with
maybe one exception household our fossil
fuel burning sectors at the lower end of
the spectrum are associated with large
emissions of aerosols and their effects
on clouds and sectors at the warmest end
of the spectrum are associated with
large emissions of ozone and black
carbon that app tube enhance the
greenhouse gas warming so one thing that
has always bothered me about this sector
oral analysis and also the single
species analysis is that it doesn't
properly take into account interactions
with land ecosystems so let me give you
a couple of examples tropospheric ozone
has a strong interaction with
terrestrial vegetation it damages the
ability of plants to optic to
photosynthesize and therefore to uptake
carbon dioxide and the effect is large
enough to represent a warming indirect
carbon dioxide forcing so that needs to
be included into these results also all
of these sectors change the atmospheric
oxidation capacity in some way they
they're all associated with a certain
nox emission and this will have a large
impact on a formation of biogenic
secondary organic aerosol which is
another climate forcing that would need
to be included here so I have begun to
think about how we can include these
interactions properly into forcing
assessments of Traverse Varrick ozone
and aerosols now land ecosystems are the
major global source of volatile organic
carbon to the atmosphere so I'm going to
talk a lot about be Vox biogenic
volatile organic carbon the source from
land ecosystems is over a Pettigrew
Murray active carbon per year this is
one percent of gpp it is a factor of 10
larger than anthropogenic v OC emission
sauce / Yerevan order of magnitude
larger and it's of comparable magnitude
to net by own production global net by a
production interestingly so the plans
are giving up this precious assimilated
carbon to protect themselves from a
biotic and a biotic stresses the
dominant compound emitted is isoprene to
the tune of about half a pet a gram of
carbon per year another important class
of compounds are monoterpenes now once
in the atmosphere there is complex
nonlinear chemical processing these
species have very short atmospheric
lifetimes so they only exist for about
half an hour before they begin a chain
oxidation reactions and these this
chemistry can alter the atmospheric
distributions of all of the short-lived
climate forces so ozone methane and
these compounds are direct precursors to
the formation of biogenic secondary
organic aerosol in fact as I assure you
later today because these compounds
influence oxidation capacity they also
affect all secondary particles in the
atmosphere including the formation of
sulfate and nitrate aerosol so the
actual impact of the bwalk emissions on
the short-lived climate forces depends
critically on the chemical background
state of the atmosphere especially the
amount of knobs so in the effect is
dependent upon co-located emissions from
anthropogenic sources so the changes in
traverse right ozone aerosols and
methane constitutes a forcing which
could ultimately feedback and change the
rate of emission of the B Vox the beaver
emission is also going to be sensitive
to land cover and potentially land cover
change we're going to talk about that
today so in the initial the original
modeling paradigm for I supreme which
came out of the air quality community
that are more concerned with
weather-related timescales I supreme was
mostly sensitive to temperature so that
modeling approach was then used in
global change studies with the idea that
oh we have a warmer future world they'll
be more isoprene and in a past cold
world that implies less I supreme then
the plant physiologists informed us that
there is a direct interaction between
atmospheric carbon dioxide and the rid
of isoprene emission and it's an inverse
relationship we call this the direct co2
inhibition effect on global modeling
studies revealed that temperature and
vegetation productivity impacts are
entirely offset by the direct
atmospheric co2 in a bishop which leaves
the atmospheric chemistry community in a
rather with a rather uncomfortable
question well is isoprene actually
rather boring and chemistry climate
interactions we've made a mistake
because it doesn't actually change much
in different climates States no it is
not it means that land use land cover
change is going to be playing the
critical role in determining vivo
commission change in different climatic
states human activities have modified 30
to 50
out of the earth's land surface through
the historical cropland expansion and
agricultural activity I find that number
completely staggering and at the moment
the community assesses the climate
impact of this historical cropland
expansion essentially as a rivalry
between the cooling surface albedo
change and the warming co2 release it
turns out that the forcing for each of
those impacts is the same magnitude but
opposite in sign so indeed now there's
no consensus in the scientific community
on the sign of the global average global
average surface air temperature change
to the historical pro planned expansion
to anthropogenic land cover change
several studies do suggest an overall
warming that the co2 effect wins out as
this one which is was done using the
eckin model but many of the emic studies
actually have the albedo effect winning
out over all and a net cooling from
anthropogenic land cover change so the
question my group is interested in is
how important is this historical land
cover change on be voc emissions
emissions of reactive chemical species
and it are the impacts large enough to
perturb the short-lived climate forces
in which case do we need to consider the
short-lived climate forces in
assessments of anthropogenic land cover
change because they're not currently
considered so I'm going to tell you
about the development of a global
modeling framework to study interactions
between
ecosystems chemistry employment and then
we'll use the model to try and answer
these three questions what is the effect
of the historical cropland expansion on
Beaver commissions and the short-lived
climate forces can we develop an
indirect climate effect of bee vac
emissions and then if i have time i will
talk about an extension of these ideas
to understanding climate sensitivity in
herbs deep past particularly in hot
worlds where the vegetation cover was
much more extensive so here's a
schematic of our model framework it is
based on NASA this model e 2 I worked on
the chemistry development of that model
for about a decade and since coming here
we have implemented into an interactive
terrestrial biosphere so essentially in
the canopy biophysics we have
implemented the very well established
Farquhar ball berry photosynthesis
tomato conductance equations which was
solving at the land surface model time
step which is dynamic 15 minutes or less
and in that canopy biophysics scheme we
have implemented a new biologically
realistic isoprene emission model the
isoprene emission is dependent upon the
electron transport limited
photosynthesis rate and also the
internal leaf carbon dioxide
concentration so also noteworthy is that
we have a dynamic simulation of CI of
the leaf internal carbon dioxide
concentration so we solve this every
land surface model time step we don't
just simply assume that it's seventy
percent of the atmospheric carbon
dioxide concentration which is what most
other dynamic vegetation models
and another unique feature of our model
is that the temporal resolution is 30
minutes so the GCM a time step again
traditional dynamic vegetation models
usually have a time step of one day
which is not very useful for atmospheric
chemistry so in my group our research
scientists are working on the
interactions with aerosols and clouds
and vegetation and also the ozone damage
I'm going to talk for the rest of today
the time that I have about the impacts
of Bevo the photosynthesis dependent
wave of emissions on chemistry climate
interactions so after a lot of work our
fluxes our carbon fluxes are and
consistent with current understanding of
the contemporary carbon cycle we have
done an extensive evaluation of the
model carbon fluxes mostly using flux
net data we have nine sites of data for
isoprene time-varying sites that we've
done a fairly detailed analysis model
does a very good job of simulating the
diurnal average variability we always
patch even with a freerunning climate
model ninety percent of the variance in
the diurnal variability the main
weakness is in simulating the magnitude
of the isoprene emission but we are
within a factor of two in dry season
tropics and in the deciduous biome which
is as good
as the super high resolution air quality
modeling systems used by the US
government okay so because the isoprene
emission is dependent on the rate of
photosynthesis it's essentially a
certain fraction of photosynthesis that
means that the isoprene emission is
sensitive to water water availability
and so some brute force sensitivity
simulations we turned off the water
stress function in the vegetation
biophysics and found a global increase
in isoprene emission of thirty percent
and we also ran the model with potential
natural vegetation and found a very
large increase in the global isoprene
sauce of fifty-five percent so this is
an indicator that anthropogenic land
cover change is going to be having a
substantial impact on the beaver
emissions so here we are looking at
results from multiple linear regression
regarding the relationship between the
model isoprene emission and its key
drivers Bruce photosynthesis and canopy
temperature on the left side here is the
standard default model and then on the
right side we have the results from
simulation turning off the water stress
artificially and the whole reason I'm
doing this is to demonstrate that in our
biologically realistic isoprene leaf
production the gross photosynthesis rate
is dominating over canopy temperature in
controlling the isoprene emission
variability on all time scales
okay so this is very different from the
previous original modeling approach for
isoprene that was simply dependent on
temperature so what we're finding is
that water stress decreases the
sensitivity of the isoprene emission
variability to canopy temperature so
this is because high temperature
conditions are associated with drought
and that actually leads to a reduction
in photosynthesis and therefore a
reduction in isoprene emission so in the
original modeling paradigm that would
actually give an increase in photo in
isoprene emission so a corollary is that
these original empirical isoprene
emission models that do not account for
the effects of water stress likely
overestimate the sensitivity of the
isoprene emission variability to a
temperature of course we would very much
like to be able to examine these
relationships between isoprene and the
drivers at large scales we haven't we
haven't got any large-scale observations
of isoprene emission what we do have our
formaldehyde columns measured from space
and our community believes that
variability in the formaldehyde column
is a good proxy for surface isoprene
emission so what we have done here is
look at the correlation between gpp from
a global flux net derived data set and
the fire free formaldehyde columns are
measured from space there's a lot of
information here and we're still
understanding everything that is going
on we can see a strong positive
relationship between photosynthesis and
isoprene emission over North America in
spring and fall and then the
relationship it becomes negative fairly
strongly negative over the United States
particularly the southeastern United
States which is a major emission region
for isoprene in the high summer and one
possible explanation for this is the
difference in temperature optimum
between photosynthesis and isoprene
synthase so isoprene synthase has a
higher optimum it's about 30 degrees c
whereas photosynthesis temperature
optimum is around 25 degrees C so I've
used the model to examine the historical
changes in isoprene emission over the
last century and also to isolate the
impacts of the key dryness so they those
are a carbon dioxide which can affect
isoprene through carbon dioxide
fertilization increasing photosynthesis
and also the direct co2 inhibition
effect anthropogenic land-cover change
and also physical climate which is
mostly going to be the effects of
temperature and precipitation so the
panels on the left here are the change
in gross photosynthesis over the last
century our model projects about a
15-percent increase due to the co2
fertilization effect and that appears to
be consistent across most regions too
and then in the right side here we're
looking at the isoprene emission change
and very interesting we so the isoprene
is coupled photosynthesis we actually
find a 20-percent of
more global decrease in isoprene
emission over the century which is
driven by anthropogenic land cover
change so even though photosynthesis
increases due to co2 fertilization in
our model the isoprene emission is
decreasing rather substantially due to
human land cover change so here we're
looking especially at the impacts of the
different drivers on isoprene emission
change in a time slice approach so
between the year 2018 80 and I think
it's quite clear that the anthropogenic
land cover change is really dominating
the global change impacts on isoprene
emission and so here's the key point if
anthropogenic land cover change is the
dominant driver of isoprene emission
change over the past century that means
that isoprene change is a climate
forcing it's a human induced climate
forcing it's not a natural feedback in
the system because temperature is
actually a very small driver of isoprene
change over the past century so in the
chemistry climate modelling community
we're not used to thinking about
isoprene as a climate forcing agent I
must say on the other hand everyone who
writes a paper or a proposal about
isoprene always says it starts off their
paper with a comment that isoprene is
important because it affects climate but
if one starts to look around there's
actually no quantitative assessment of
exactly how much I supreme affects
climate and how so to unlock new ways of
thinking
about isoprene and climate I'm showing
here the contribution lubali of Beaver
emissions to the short-lived climate
forces in terms of a radiative effect
and the numbers are huge so that ozone
relative effect is double the
anthropogenic ozone radiative forcing
since the pre-industrial so these
results demonstrate quite clearly that
be VOC emissions globally have a
profound influence on Travis Varrick
ozone methane and biogenic secondary
organic aerosol composition there are
also influences on sulfate and nitrate
aerosol because be VOC emissions change
atmospheric oxidation capacity the
effect of be voc emissions on the
relative effects of the short-lived
climate forces is different in different
climate states it depends on essentially
the NOx background atmosphere so if we
take the difference between these two
climate states the pre-industrial which
is this 1850 atmosphere is already
influenced by human activities so
there's a substantial amount of nox from
deforestation burning and from domestic
biofuel burning but if if we take the
difference this will give us a new
diagnostic that I'm calling the latent
indirect effect on climate of Beaver
Commission's so part of that is due to
the beaver commission change and part of
it is due to the change in background
chemical background atmosphere which
affects the oxidation impacts of the
beaver emissions so there's this latent
indirect effect is a minus point 1 watt
per meter squared so it's not a trivial
amount
it's approximately half the sulphate
pre-industrial to present their forcing
and it's a cooling so because we know
that my supreme is affected by human
activities and is therefore a climate
forcing we have gone ahead and computed
done idealized perturbation experiments
to derive the relative efficiency in
different biomes of be VOC emissions so
I'm showing the results here for the
tropical temperate and boreal zones and
what's interesting is we find the same
response pattern across all biomes so
ozone is the largest impact with
biogenic secondary organic aerosol has
the second largest impact and then
methane except in the boreal where
biogenic secondary organic aerosol has
the largest impact but it's a net
positive forcing across all biomes it's
a net positive forcing and the tropical
be vaca emissions have the highest net
positive relative efficiency and to give
you a sense of how important this is
these numbers are a twenty five percent
increase in tropical be VOC emissions
has the same global warming impact as
the entire global aviation sector since
the great acceleration of the 1950s so
including the historical co2 forcing in
the aviation impact so that's that's not
a small effect and it's very relevant
for energy crops in in the tropics oil
palm plantations
here I've converted the relative
efficiencies in each biome to a global
warming potential and it's undeniable
that the beaver commission changes have
substantial impacts on regional and
global relative balance global radiative
balance so beaver Commission's are only
1% of gpp the small flocks are very
reactive Colin but have
disproportionately large impacts on
planet through perturbing the
short-lived climate forces it's very
encouraging that our results are broadly
consistent with previous assessments of
GW ps4 androgenic EOC emissions which
are of course emitted in a magnitude of
about a factor of 10 lower than V voc
emissions globally so what happens when
we put everything together so we're
looking at the pre-industrial to
present-day radiative forcing by
short-lived climate forces there are
androgenic emission changes and now
we're including the biogenic changes so
here i'm showing that as an not
including anthropogenic land cover
change and including anthropogenic land
cover change the main effect is an
implied thirty percent smaller
pre-industrial to present-day ozone
radiative forcings the main impact is on
ozone the biogenic secondary organic
aerosol forcing globally is small but
inclusion of anthropogenic land cover
change that and the beaver commission
changes therefore alters the sign from
negative to positive it may be that the
biogenic secondary organic aerosol
changes have more of a regional impact
for example when we include
anthropogenic land cover change we find
this large positive biogenic secondary
organic aerosol forcing over the eastern
United States so I'm going to finish now
with this last slide in past hot
climates vegetation cover was a much
more extensive and so we have looked at
dynamic simulations of emissions of B
box from terrestrial ecosystems and also
wildfire in several past hot planet so
one of them is the pliocene so this was
three million years ago the earth was
about two to three degrees warmer than
it is today and it's been difficult to
explain several features structural
features of this climate state on the
external forcing by co2 and by changes
in surface albedo so we have so what
actually happens in the pliocene is
there's an expansion of the tropical
savanna into area that semi-arid and
desert today and there's also a
proliferation of deciduous forests
deciduous is a very high isoprene
emitter and tropical savanna is
extremely fire-prone so we dynamically
simulated the emissions natural
emissions are from wildfires and be
verbs and find substantial implied
forcings between the pliocene and print
pre-human pre-industrial atmospheres so
this is largely due actually to the
vegetation
the change which alters the emission
magnitude so we get about a hundred
percent increase in biomass burning
relative to the pre human pre-industrial
and fifty percent of more increase in
beaver emissions so we find substantial
ozone and carbonaceous aerosol forcings
now notice the magnitude of these
forcings is very comparable to
anthropogenic chemical forcings they're
about the same number so atmospheric
chemistry is not an anthropogenic
phenomenon chemical forcing of climate
is always happening in the Earth's
system in a hot world then will the
atmosphere will always be full of ozone
and carbonaceous aerosols from burning
and vegetation so in summary we have
developed the Yalie to global carbon
chemistry climate model it couples
vegetation biophysics and atmospheric
chemistry at high temporal resolution
within a global climate model framework
so prior to now the global modeling of
carbon cycle climate and global modeling
of chemistry climate have evolved as
entirely separate communities for
understandable reasons but that's no
longer appropriate so this is our first
attempt to put everything together and
we find that anthropogenic land-cover
change implies higher beaver emissions
in the pre-industrial than the present
day world up until now in chemistry
climate modelling communities beaver
Commission's were either being held the
same in the pre-industrial world or were
being assumed to be less because of
lower temperatures and the implication
of this is the bee vac emission
for the historical anthracene are a
climate forcing a human induced climate
forcing not a natural feedback in the
system and our results so far we have a
lot of work to do on this project but
the results so far certainly suggest
that assessments of anthropogenic land
cover change climate impact do need to
consider the short-lived climate forces
this is of course very relevant in
forestry for climate protect protection
strategies biofuel policy and energy
crops and also our results are important
for deciding the processes that need to
be included in climate models for a
potential a or six assessment and
finally I will finish up saying that
beaver Commission's likely play an
important role in the Earth's climate
sensitivity thank you very much for
listening